on the shot clock couldn't make it
rebounded by covington
lasers at the treasure every possession
down the stretch here with 220 on the
clock down 13.
here's lillard another one that one
wouldn't go
and then a collision between caruso and
james
everybody's all right
[Applause]
schroeder leaning in couldn't get it and
trying to save it does again we've seen
him do that a couple times making a
great save
meanwhile covington is already wearing a
mask
holding his face there empty possession
for the lakers
[Applause]
lebron james and steph curry two of the
all-time drinks
where else is a step back
moving the game forward due to health
and safety protocols he had 22 points
tonight on 14 shots made all his free
throws
played 30 minutes in his first game back
giving the lakers another offensive
weapon
and a guy to help their defense as james
will go to the free-throw line here with
47 seconds left
yeah shooter is impressive 22 points we
were talking about
gary trent jr 19 points on 20 shots
where you got schroeder here with 22
points on 14 shots
9 for 9 from the free throw line so
having his efficiency
and his defense back has been so
important to the lakers tonight
our nba saturday primetime game on abc
and the espn app
uh espn app features some other mvp
candidates luca doncic james harden
kyrie irving
our coverage starts with nba countdown
at eight eastern time brooklyn is the
hottest team in the nba right now with
the jazz losing tonight the nets have
won eight
in a row they're 22-12 just a half game
behind philadelphia coming into tonight
for the best record in the east
[Applause]
some blood on the basketball dallas is
playing a little bit
better as well but still under 500
but a little surprising i know porzingis
was out they've had a ton of injuries as
well
[Applause]
would you say dallas has been a
disappointment or is that unfair
i think it's a bit unfair i think we've
seen a lot of teams go through these
tough stretches the best team in the nba
thus far has been the utah jazz
no real covet situations and they've
only had three different starting
lineups which is the best in the nba
so you're gonna see the best team has
had the lease issues and
you're gonna see teams like dallas who
struggled uh without porzingis and just
with covet situations
so uh it's going to be fun to see teams
like san antonio golden state dallas
denver and memphis battle for those last
few spots because
you know that second half of the
schedule that that you know after the
all-star break
you know all of these teams don't have a
lot of room for error
28 points for lebron james he's had
three 30-point games in his last
five and then
seeking another one here tonight
missed the second free throw but got the
rebound and